[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
not only that i
fell on the floor but i knocked over my
chair
something else and then i collapsed on
the ground
and tyra and mj held me while i was on
the ground
crying this is major like let's take a
second
let this all sink in because this is
historic
what does this moment feel like for you
today it makes me feel like
i'm my ancestors wildest dreams
feels like everything that they went
through everything that they
were faced through their trials and
tribulations allowed me to be here to
receive this opportunity
and their breathing right through me
just 10 years ago
the idea of being a trans person in any
way
shape or form in public eye in public
space
especially in entertainment was
non-existent we were born to do what
we're doing
did you ever honestly imagine that your
career
would bring you to this point
honestly no i really didn't um
yes this is the olympics of modeling for
us
so first off there's not many trans
representations especially of color in
the fashion world so the fact
that we have literally said
forget about that we're just gonna put
you on the cover and be the embodiment
of
what exactly we need in the world i
think that was
kind of like we have three
women of color on this magazine cover
from all different walks of life and i
think we we
need this moment listen you mentioned
three different covers megan the
stallion and naomi osaka these are two
incredible women two powerful women
what do you appreciate about each of
them
um authentic myths to just be
be themselves you know to to have those
tough conversations
to say no i deserve better no i'm
important also
let me just be myself i love that about
them i love that
when you go to their pages they're
talking about mental health they're
talking about education they're talking
about
visibility they're talking about how
important is the body
to be out of yada yada you know what it
means
exactly so it's just it's a universal
language that we can talk about all
around the world
i mean you were on pose incredible show
your co-star mj rodriguez just also made
history she is the first trans woman
up for a lead acting category mj
is a powerful powerful woman i remember
seeing her
on the first episode of season one of
pose and i text her right away and i
said
what you are doing is going to change
the world do you know how important
this is that we need this the same thing
i said to my sister india more
i was raised by the old school cats you
know what i mean like
i know how hard they worked i know what
they went through i knew the time that
they were born into where they
had to just be quiet now we're in a time
when we
can't stop talking we cannot stop
winning we cannot stop reaching to the
top
of the mountaintop and that's exactly
where we deserve to be
and if anyone is tired of this baby we
just getting started so
get ready
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos